arithmetic the floating-point operations
and the communication and that's going
to be moving data either between levels
of a memory hierarchy of which there
could be many or between processors over
network so here's going to be my very
simple model to measure the optimality
of an algorithm I'll count the number of
flops count the number of words moved
say between two processors and I'll
count the number of messages and the
message is a contiguous chunk of words
that have been packed together to move
and all three of those have separate
costs associated with them and so the
hardware parameters are the time / flop
the reciprocal band width or the time
per word and the latency cost for the
message the last two being the
communication and as people in this
audience probably know these three
Hardware performers parameters or orders
of magnitude apart it costs an order of
magnitude more time to move a word than
it does to do a floating point operation
and technological trends are making
these gaps grow asymptotically in time
so thanks to Moore's law and multi-core
the time for flop is getting better at
fifty nine percent a year and everything
else is getting better but much more
slowly so even if your algorithm is not
communication bound today it may be next
year the year after that so our first
goal is to avoid communication to save
time but that's not the only reason here
is a plot of the energy it takes to
perform the basic operations in the
machine on a log scale so a double
precision floating point operation in
today's technology takes a hundred Pico
jewels the prediction is in 2018 it'll
take ten times less here the next three
bars are the jewels it takes to move
data on ship and these three bars of the
data of the energy it takes to move off
chip certain distances and so you can
see it's an order and a one and a half
orders of magnitude more expensive per
operation to move data off ship today
and everything's getting better so it'll
be two and a half orders of magnitude
more expensive per operation to move
data off chip in five years so whether
you're worried about the battery in your
laptop dying or the million dollars per
megawatt per year it costs you on your
data center you want to avoid
communication to save energy so here are
the goals of this research agenda and my
talk so what I want to do is redesign
all algorithms to avoid communication
that means in all senses between all
levels of memory hierarchy l1 and l2
cache l2 and DRAM networks and so forth
and whenever possible prove
or bounds and prove that our new
algorithms attained the lower bounds and
we'll see that's going to give us very
large speed ups and energy savings now
this work has taken sort of three
different directions and in my half hour
I can only talk about two of them so
I'll start by talking about direct
linear algebra so new algorithms and
asked that are asymptotically faster for
matrix multiply will always start there
Lu QR I can value problems singular
value decomposition tensor contractions
all of that it's all possible for
iterative linear algebra to so conjugate
gradient algorithms things like that I
will just have a one slide summary but
and it turns out that all the ideas that
we had for direct linear algebra work
for any algorithm that accesses arrays
that's all we need to assume about it
that we're accessing arrays and that the
subscripts are somehow linear functions
of your loop indices now you don't have
to take my word for it that this is a
good idea you can take the word of
somebody at a higher pay scale say
President Obama so here's here's a quote
from the department of energy budget
request for 2012 and it says on modern
computer architectures communication is
more expensive and floating-point and so
to minimize communication you have to
reformulate all the communication
patterns and make it work better so this
is referring to the truly knows project
which is a widely used parallel solver
developed at Sandia so I asked and we
collaborate with him so I asked my Carew
what they were talking about he says its
algorithms that we developed here and it
was done by my PhD student Mark Holman
who now works on truly knows both
communicating avoiding GM res and the
tall skinny QR algorithm that David
gleich talked about earlier this week so
anyway just to give you some motivation
so here's the outline of the talk I'm
going to survey the state of the art in
direct linear algebra and I'll spend my
time I'll go into detail in one
particular algorithm n cubed it's
classical n cube matrix multiply but it
now goes asymptotically faster than it
did before but earlier in the week we've
already heard three other talks so i'll
just refer to them so item bullish
talked about all pairs shortest path
using floyd-warshall same idea that goes
asymptotically faster david like talked
about tall skinny QR which is a building
block for lots of things and then gray
Ballard talked about communicating
avoiding straße but so i'll just refer
back to that then i'll have a few slides
on how we go beyond linear algebra to
anything that accesses arrays and a one
slide summary of iterative method
so let me start with a survey of what
the lower bounds are for direct linear
algebra and then how to attain it and so
this is this holds for anything that
smells like three nested loops and we
have a formal definition of smells like
but your intuition is perfectly good
right now so let's let em be the fast
memory size and and the problem is too
big to fit in there so I want to bound
the communication that has to occur into
and out of that fast memory and the
answer is that the words moved for every
processor is lower bounded by however
many flops that processor happens to do
divided by the square root of its local
memory size and in the parallel case to
sort of interpret this you can think of
being load balance for the flops per
processor is one piece of the total
flops and the memory it has is one piece
of the total memory so people have known
this for a long time so Hong income
proved this back in 81 or so for
sequential matrix multiply but now as i
said we know it holds for just about
everything so it holds for the basic
linear algebra subroutines for gaussian
elimination any variant of it QR
eigenvalue problems SVD tensor
contractions it holds for whole programs
that executes sequences of these
operations so you can do multiple matrix
multiplies and no matter how you
interleave those multiple operations the
lower bound still holds its true for
both dense and sparse matrices so the
number of flops doesn't have to be in
cubed anymore it's however many
operations that your sparse algorithm
happens to do you can you can flip coins
in the inner loop to decide what to do
and it's still however many flops that
are done at the end it holds for
sequential and parallel algorithms and
indeed you don't have to do multiplies
and adds you can do you know other semi
ring operations and that's the
floyd-warshall algorithm that item
bullish talked about before so that's
the bandwidth lower bound so what about
the number of messages so the simplest
way to get a lower bound on that is to
say i'm going to send the largest
possible messages so i'll take the
number of words i have to move / the
largest message size and that will give
me a lower bound on the number of
messages what's the lower bound on the
big on the method what how big a message
can i send the whole memory so i'm just
going to take this bound and / m and is
just going to change the exponent and
that's going to be my goal to send that
few messages and i'm pleased to say that
won a best paper prize so given these
lower bounds the next question is can we
attain them or rather the first question
should be
do the existing algorithms and libraries
like la pack and scale a pack and so
forth attain them the answer is hardly
ever not even for matrix multiply so we
can we have there's lots of rooms for
improvement and so for basically all of
dense linear algebra and in some sparse
too we've been reinventing it their new
algorithms their new numerical
properties we can't for example do
partial pivoting anymore we need to do
new kind of pivoting in order to attain
the lower bounds new data structures and
ways to encode the answers I mean we
have to do loop transformations too but
that's not the only thing and we're now
in the process of putting that into all
the standard libraries we can do some
sparse algorithms you can imagine that
you know if your matrices are too sparse
you're not going to be able to attain
these lower bounds but that's another
talk so let me just stick with a dense
case here and ditto for iterative linear
algebra so let me now ask what these
lower bounds tell us about the parallel
case and so what I'm going to do it just
be concrete I'm going to assume I of n
by n matrices keep everything square on
P processors and I need to plug in the
memory per processor into the lower
bound so let me make a reasonable
sounding assumption that i use as little
memory as possible so every processor
owns one piece of the data so i'll plug
that into the denominator so when i use
the lower bounds each processor does one
piece of the work and m is plugged in
there and so there are my two lower
bounds that i want to compare la scala
pack too so it turns out that for the
number of words move the bandwidth costs
Kayla pack typic usually attains lower
bounds except for the non symmetric
eigenvalue problem it's much much worse
but for the number of messages it hardly
ever attains lower bound its way
asymptotically more communication than
necessary and so our first step was to
reinvent all those algorithms and so we
can attain the lower bounds for both
bandwidth latency for all of that but
then we asked ourselves can we do better
and so that seems little strange because
I just said we attained a lower bound
but I made an assumption which was I
used as little memory as possible
there's the lower bounds are still true
even if the memory is larger than the
minimum that you need so can we attain
it I wouldn't ask the question if the
answer weren't yes so let's go on and do
that so I'm going to talk about our two
and a half dimensional matrix multiply
algorithm and so I'm going to assume
that I have not enough memory just for
one copy but I can fit see copies the
data where C is you one or two or three
whatever so you can replicate the data
and going to take my P processors in
form a two-and-a-half dimensional grid
the classical algorithm forms a 2d
gridded processors root P by root P so
I'm going to form a 3d grid two and a
half D grid c by p / c square root and
so forth so that's what my processor
grid is going to look like and i'm going
to assume my data is not replicated to
begin with it's just living in the top
so that processor owns that particular
sub matrix of a and that sub matrix of B
and so forth so that's how it's all
spread out and i'm going to index all
the LDN processors by IJ and k and as i
said at the beginning that the data is
only distributed across the top so
what's the algorithm it's very simple at
the beginning at the top of a column
broadcasts its sub matrices to everybody
below it so everybody owns a copy then
each layer is going to run one C of the
classical algorithm communication
optimal algorithm which is called Summa
so it's going to compete do one sees of
the work one sees of the communication
and compute a partial sum of all the
data then the last step all the partial
sums in one column I'll just do a sum
reduce and the right answer will appear
at the top and if you do all the
arithmetic it turns out to hit the lower
bound so the question is does this bias
anything how about a factor of 12 so so
here's an example of a speed-up so this
is on a 64,000 core bgp a very small
matrix of size 8 k you wouldn't think
you'd want to use that many processors
on on an 8k by AK matrix and also a
bigger one and the vertical axis is
percentage of peak so up is good 100 is
a max and if you just run the classical
to D algorithm with no replication
you're getting like two percent of peak
which it's not worth using that many
processors but we go 12 times faster if
we do the replication now if you run the
larger problem then it's much not as
communication bound so we only get a two
point seven XP de so let me show you
what the timing breakdown is for this so
the same experiment but now i'm going to
show you where the time goes in
communication idle and computation so
this is all normalized to the classical
algorithm running in time one and so you
can see it's spending this much time
doing communication and it goes down by
ninety-five percent so the red bar goes
down very small the idle time goes away
and even the flops go faster so why is
that that's because I'm locally
multiplying larger sub matrices on each
processors to the local blahs three run
faster so that's where we get that speed
up on the larger problem it's not nearly
so the green part the communicate the
compute stays the same it's not nearly
as communication bound but so I only get
a 2.78 speed up but if that's where all
your energy went into the communication
I might have just saved you ninety five
percent of the energy so i'm pleased to
say this one another paper prize so so
this algorithm has a nice property which
is it gives you perfect strong scaling
in both time and energy so what does
perfect strong scaling mean well I mean
let me define it so every time you add a
processor and you want to go faster
you're not just getting the hardware
resource of the processor you're getting
its memory too so you might as well use
you've already paid for it so what I'm
going to do is ask let me start with as
few processors as it takes to fit all
three matrices into memory so three N
squared just barely fits and I'm going
to increase the number of processors by
a factor of C and use all the memory the
extras factor of C memory too and see
what happens so I'm going to write down
a performance model so i need the
seconds per flop the seconds per word
moved the reciprocal bandwidth and the
seconds per message and i can write down
this kind of messy formula for the time
it takes to run on C times P processors
and all I want you to notice is how it
scales and it scales perfectly it's C
times faster the flop time goes down by
a factor of C the bandwidth and the
latency they all go down by a factor of
C so that's perfect strong scaling in
time what about energy so I've run this
energy model past our Hardware
colleagues so they kind of buy it and so
i'm going to count the number of joules
per flop the joules per word moved along
the network the joules per message but
of course there's other places you burn
energy so the memory is burning energy
no matter what happens so i'm going to
count the joules per word per second
that the memory is burning and then also
the leakage and all the other of the
fans and whatever that's another term
and so let me just write down a long
messy formula for the energy it takes to
run on C times P processors and all i
care about is how it scales and it
scales perfectly it doesn't matter how
fast you solve it it takes the same
amount of energy to solve it C times
faster so how can that be I'm each
processor is burning the same amount of
power and i have p times as many of them
c times as many of them but they all run
one sees as long so the energy is
constant so so that's a nice property
that these algorithms have
and it's not just matrix multiply it
applies to end body and Strawson and all
sorts of things so let me just sort of
summarize some of the ongoing work in
this we have lots of other algorithms
from which we can do all this stuff as i
said the blahs lu symmetric and definite
factorization QR there's lots of you
know innovation required in pivoting we
have to get rid of all the old pivoting
schemes and do new ones because the old
ones were very communication expensive
and because this is a big data
conference let me just mention we
figured out how to do QR with column
pivoting how do you select the most
independent columns and hit these lower
bounds we have some sparse matrix
algorithms that's another long talk you
can imagine I mean there's no magic if
you multiply two diagonal matrices ian
of the lower bound is not attainable but
if you make some assumptions so for
example sparse cholesky we can do for
certain sparsity structures we can
attain the lower bounds it's running on
so and we just proved a new lower bound
I should mention that if you increase
see in in the case of matrix multiply
the bandwidth and the latency went down
and we attained it but if you're doing
lu or QR is something where you have a
dependency from the top corner to the
bottom corner the latency is minimized
with one copy of the data and so if you
want so the lower bound says if you want
to minimize bandwidth copies help if you
want to minimize latency one copy is the
best so depending on your hardware costs
you may or may not choose due to the
replication we're sort of putting this
in all sorts of different platforms i'm
not sure if david like mentioned like we
get 13 x speed ups on a GPU for doing
our yeah there's lots of speed up
numbers you know 13 x speed ups on a GPU
for tall skinny QR and so on and so
forth and we're integrating this into
all these libraries and also into lots
of packages so for example tensor
contractions smells enough like three
nested loops that all of the ideas he
reply and they're a bunch of quantum
chemists who spend all their time doing
tensor contractions and quantum
chemistry so that's getting integrated
into a package called the cyclops tensor
framework that the quantum chemistry
computer community is using okay so now
let me go beyond linear algebra and say
how all this all this extends to kind of
arbitrary code that accesses arrays and
I'm going to illustrate it instead of
stating the general result first I'll
just apply it to some simple examples so
let's go back to matrix multiply here's
the classic unoptimized naive code three
nested loops
over I J&K and there i'm doing the
matrix multiply and we've all known for
a long time that if you want to minimize
the communication and this is to level
memory model perfectly sequential what
am I going to do i'm just going to block
the code i'm going to break up my
matrices into B by B Block so this
square bracket now refers to a sub
matrix and I'll have three nested loops
but it's over blocks and the inner loop
is doing a B by B matrix multiply and as
we've all known for a long time if I
pick the block size right just a little
bit less than M to the one half so that
these three blocks all fit in too fast
memory then that attains the lower bound
which is n cubed over m to the one half
so the question is where do all these
one half's come from so now let me tell
you what the new theorem says apply just
to matrix multiply so here's the code
and all I need to know about the code
I'm going to write down in this little 3
by 3 matrix it just tells me which
arrays have which subscripts so there's
one column for each loop index I JK one
row for each array and there's a 1
because a has I as a subscript and K as
a subscript but not J that's everything
I need to know so that like the theory
goes on to say I need to solve a little
three by three linear program with this
matrix so the linear program says please
maximize the sum of the x's subject to
delta x x is less than or equal to 1 and
out pops one-half one-half one-half and
the sum of the x's the value of the
linear program is three-halves i'm going
to give that a name called s sub hbl hbl
are the acronyms of three famous
mathematicians you can guess who they
are but i'll tell you in a couple of
slides so the theorem says that no
matter how you reorganize this algorithm
the optimal communication is n cubed the
number of loop indices / m to the magic
answer minus one that's where that one
half comes from and the is detained by
block sizes em to the X I xjx k or em to
the one-half M to the one-half m to the
one half so let me just apply it again
to another example which is direct and
body see if it tells us anything so
there I have two nested loops I take
every pair of particles compute the
force and I have the same little matrix
it has one column for each loop index
one row for each array access and ones
and zeros I'm going to solve a little
even smaller linear program and it out
pops the solution 11
and the sum is too that's the S sub hbl
and so the theorem says that no matter
how i reorganize this and body algorithm
then i have to move at least as many
words the number of loop iterations and
square divided by m to the power 1 and
is attained by these block sizes so
let's see if that gives us anything and
the point is this applies even when M is
bigger than the amount of data right I
can do this replication trick so let's
see how much faster I go and again I get
a 12 x speed up by using this trick to
do the n-body algorithm so I'm so this
is an N body algorithm where I'm using
32,000 particles on 8,000 cores this
seems silly it's four particles per core
it seems like it'll be totally
communication bound and indeed if I only
have one copy of the data C equals 1
then this is this vertical axis is
running time the red is compute and the
green is communication and I'm spending
all my time communicating but if I have
two copies the data or four copies of
the data do the replication trick
eventually the communication goes away
entirely it's completely compute compute
bound as I would hope and I get perfect
strong scaling so so for those of you in
the database world you might recognize
that join looks exactly the same as this
if you run the classical joint algorithm
and so this hopefully might give us
speed ups there of course join has lots
of other you know optimizations to I
don't want to go into but it's the same
it's the same analysis so now let me
apply the theorem one more time to a
random code and random power point too
so why did it do do that let me let me
just start over okay so I basically
wrote down random code I decided let me
have six nested loops the loop indices
are going to be i1 through I six and I
just write wrote down some random
subscripts in the middle and what does
my theorem tell me so everything I need
to know about this code i encode in the
6 by 6 matrix with six columns one for
each loop index six rows one for each
array and what I'm going to do is solve
the same little six by six linear
program and out pops this bunch of
numbers whatever they mean and their sum
is 15 7s that's the S sub hbl so the
theorem says that no matter how i
reorganize this code then I can't move
fewer than n to the six the number of
loop iterations / m 2
the 15 7 s minus one that's optimal and
it's attained by these block sizes that
where the exponents just come out of the
solution of the linear program this is
not real code is just you know an
example so now let me tell you summarize
the high-level what's the theory behind
all this all the theory for linear
algebra extends to any code where I can
basically have an inner loop that I
access that I execute and I can index it
by a bunch of integers right d integers
so the easiest thing to do is think of D
nested loops but i could write recursive
code it could be anything i just have to
be able to index the inner loop then the
arrays in the inner loop r sub scripted
by arbitrary linear functions of these
indices so for example i could refer to
a sub i 1 i 2 minus I 13 I 1-4 I to know
whatever linear combinations you want
and it's also okay to have pointers I
mean it doesn't have to be really an
array all I need is that once I have
this linear function I have that gives
me a unique memory location so i could
have hash tables and whatever you want
five minutes good so and it can be dense
or sparse I mean I don't have to do you
know a cube here like a matrix multiply
can be I can have an arbitrary subset of
sparse stuck so the theory that that we
use is based on a recent result in pure
mathematics by this team of pure
mathematicians including my colleague
Mike Crist who's a collaborator in this
Terry Tao at UCLA and it's a
generalization of a whole bunch of
classical inequalities from functional
analysis including holders inequality
and the brass can't bleep inequality and
now you see where hbl comes from and
loomis whitney and so forth and so what
we can do using their theory is right
down a linear program with one
inequality / subgroup of ZD there are a
lot of subgroups of ZD but I'll get to
that and the solution this linear
program is that magic exponent s of hbl
that I was showing you before and the
theorem says that the number of words
move no matter how you reorganize that
code is lower bounded by the number of
loop iterations / m to that magic
exponent that comes out of this linear
program now this looks like a problem to
write down this linear program because
there's an infinite number of subgroups
of ZD so what ZD is the group of d
tuples of integers under addition right
that's that's an abelian group so the
question is can I write down the lower
bound so it turns out that even though
there's seem to be an infinite number
qualities they're still really only
finitely many because the coefficients
are constrained to be in a range from
zero to the dimension so there really
only are a finite number of inequalities
the trick is to find them and write them
down so when we first worked on this we
have bad news it turned out that if you
actually want to write down every
inequality that could come up its
equivalent to solving hilbert's 10th
problem over the rational numbers now we
all know what Hilbert's tenth problem
over the integers is that was proved
undecidable back in the 60s that's the
question of you're given an integer
polynomial does it have an integer
solution that's undecidable on the other
hand there's also Hilbert tense problem
over the reals does a real polynomial
have a real solution that's tarski
decidable we've known that for a long
time so q is in between this problem has
been open for 40 years nobody knows if
it's decidable or not so that kind of
got us stuck for a while but but then we
realize it's possible to write down
another linear program it's decidable to
write down another linear program that
provably has the same solution so we
don't have to trigger hilbert's 10th
problem so everything is decidable the
complexity is nuts right now but we're
working on that and it's in even better
news is in the special cases that I
showed you where the subscripts of your
arrays or just subsets of the loop
indices it's easy to write it down it's
just that Delta matrix so it's very easy
to write down so then the obvious
question is can i attain these lower
back and clearly this is going to depend
on the loop dependencies right if I have
strange enough code so that there's only
one correct iteration order that I can
go through the loops I have no freedom
at all to reorganize it so let me assume
in the best case that either there are
no dependencies or like matrix multiply
their reduction so I have total freedom
and reorganizing it then what we can
prove is that when the subscripts are
just subsets of indices like in linear
algebra and body or join the dual linear
program tells us the optimal block sizes
so all those examples i showed you
before with the dual of the linear
program that comes out of the theory of
functional analysis and that covers all
these different examples now we've been
trying to you know do lots of other
examples and we've never not been able
to attain the lower bound so we're we
conjecture that we can always a chain
attain the lower bound module of those
dependencies but that remains an open
problem so I only have a minute left and
I'm going to have a one slide summary of
how this all works for iterative methods
and so what is an iterative method I
want to solve ax equal B or solve an
eigenvalue problem I have a sparse
matrix and if I take K steps of the
algorithm what does it do I'm going to
Duke a sparse matrix vector multiplies
I'm going to get K vectors I'll take
some linear combination of those vectors
and I'll get a solution of my linear of
my of my problem and there's you know 50
years of development of these kinds of
methods conjugate gradient GM res land
shows and so forth so what I want to do
is minimize communication and to make it
easy to understand let me assume the
matrix is well partitions that means I
can sort of divide it up in a graph
partitioning sense with very few edges
crossing from one partition to another
so let me say what the serial case is so
what does a conventional algorithm do i
Luke a sparse matrix vector multiplies
the matrix is too big to fit in cash so
I have to move it k times from slow to
fast memory so that communication cost
grows like k it turns out that for all
these algorithms where you can
reorganize it to touch the data once and
still take K steps of the algorithm one
is a lower bound right so there that's
there's a lot of algebra here that I'm
going to skip that's the serial case
what about the parallel case so I've
spread out my matrix over P processors
the conventional algorithm is going to
do take K steps what's that going to
cost me at each step I have to talk to
my neighboring processors get some data
from them and I also have to probably do
a dot product so that's a reduction it's
going to cost me log P messages do the
tree and so the cost is going to grow
like K log P we can reorganize it so
it's independent of K again it costs you
one reduction to take K steps of the
algorithm and so there's a lot to say
here there's lots of speed up possible
we have implementations it's all is
going to a bunch of do e codes and the
price we pay sometimes is redundant
computation but that's okay because
flops are very cheap that's the whole
theme of this meeting of this talk and
there's a lot of challenges though what
if your matrix is not well partitioned
well we can handle some cases and I can
talk about that for some time numerical
stability there are a lot of ways to do
it the obvious ways are completely
numerically unstable you get garbage
because it round off and so you have to
pick the right way to do it and so let
me just say this is a lot of ongoing
work and for those details you can find
a lot of papers at our website I teach
you know part of my parallel computing
course which is broadcast by the NSF now
so you can all listen to me blather on
about it next semester at great length
it's all available there and so let me
just say that this is a team and there
are a lot of people who are working on
this in lots of different supporting
organizations so thank you very much and
the summary is it's time to redesign
everything linear algebra code and body
algorithm software and compilers because
all of this analysis you know you think
compilers could do it and we are
collaborating with the compiler
community now and the thing that's going
to make it all work is don't communic